you probably get bitten by mosquitoes a
couple of times a year
and there's a good chance you've been
stung by a Hornet at least once in your
life but one creature you don't want to
get bitten by is this thing this is a
tick and just one tick bite can affect
you for the rest of your life so what
would it be like to get bitten by 1
million of them how can this bite make
you sick how could you survive this mass
attack and what would the lasting
effects be this is what if and here's
what would happen if you were bitten by
1 million ticks ticks can't jump or fly
instead they wait on tall pieces of
grass or something to come by that they
can start biting
then they latch on to their hosts and
find a thin piece of skin they can
extract blood from so what would getting
bitten by just a single tick feel like
well one of the scariest parts of being
bitten by a single tick is that you
wouldn't feel it at all at least not as
it happens these things are so small
that they can stay on your body for days
without being detected
so one bite wouldn't bother you but what
about a couple hundred tick bites if
this were to happen you still might not
feel all the ticks piercing into your
skin instead you'd feel hundreds of
these creatures crawling around your
body even with a couple hundred ticks on
you it would be hours before you began
to feel the effects that's because ticks
usually take hours to find their feeding
spot on your body once they choose a
spot then they'll begin to suck your
blood
they feed on you for a couple of hours
you begin to feel light-headed and maybe
even nauseous from the blood you've lost
and tic saliva has anticoagulants which
will thin your blood making you bleed
even more if you had 5,000 tics drinking
your blood the blood loss could kill you
that's because an average tick can suck
up to one milliliter of your blood and
you have up to fifty five hundred
milliliters of blood in your body but
they need to feed on you for hours to do
that the good thing about a tick bite is
that it doesn't happen instantly instead
these bites are a long process and can
take up to 48 hours before the tick is
finished drinking your blood if 1
million ticks attacked you that would
feel pretty terrible if they fed on you
for long enough you would certainly die
not to mention that all that extra
weight on your body would probably
suffocate you but if you did happen to
get medical attention fast enough and
got all the ticks off of you then
there's a good chance you'd be ok once
you reach to the hospital dozens of
doctors and nurses would have to
carefully find and remove every single
tick from your body that's because after
the ticks latch on they start to burrow
into your skin they're not something you
can easily just brush off instead it
requires a precise extraction to get
them out of you it would take hours
maybe even days to get every single tick
off your body throughout this process
you've continued to lose blood luckily
if you remove to them fast enough you'd
end up surviving but if you leave just a
single tick on your body the
consequences could be devastating
one tick drinking your blood would be
the least of your worries
ticks can give you plenty of other
health problems including Lyme disease
this tick borne illness would make you
incredibly fatigued and could lead to
joint pain and heart issues you could
end up a bedridden from just a single
tick bite and this could last for years
if not treated properly so if you didn't
manage to get every single tick off of
you there's a good chance you'd end up
with Lyme disease and even after
treatment you could still experience
symptoms like difficulty thinking and
continued fatigue so yeah a single tick
bite could change your life now if you
ever find yourself walking in some tall
grassy fields remember to check
everywhere on your body for ticks
afterwards and we mean everywhere ticks
can hide in your hair your armpits and
even your groin being bitten by ticks
sure does suck but how do they compare
to murder Hornets well we'll leave that
story for another what-if
[Music]